[Music]
william is that a thumbs up dom we got a
thumbs up from liv we're back we're here
back in the studio and we've been away
traveling we go we come back
i'm liking the new studio i just had to
go at the dart board there yeah you got
a a miss a miss and an eight is that
good that's it's not bad but i feel like
we need better darts i feel those darts
the flights are not oh it's the floor
not what i would expect
what's that phrase about carpenters
blaming tools i don't know but
um so some people have been saying they
were sad uh the youtube
uh listeners well that's what you're
watching and listening
or slightly disappointed that they
didn't get to see the studio so cut away
to dartboard
what a wonderful dart ball look at that
but we need better doubts
maybe at the same time we could cut away
to the uh billion doll eat the world uh
food and beverage uh shelf the shelf of
goodness shall we oh nice okay we'll
call it shelf of goodness from now on
there's other shelves here that has a
our reward
i don't think it is an award but i'm
calling it
we've got a hundred thousand viewers on
uh youtube subscribers we want two
hundred thousand of course we do we'll
never be happy to no no we won't once we
get two hundred thousand i want a
million yeah yeah i've just skipped half
a million that's fine was that half a
million maths
half a million five hundred thousand
uh but does that end up being seven
hundred thousand because two hundred
thousand plus five hundred thousand is
seven hundred thousand yeah but then
then another three hundred thousand will
get a million then that's a million but
once we get million i want two million
yeah of course how many people are in
the world
is it
six billion that's how many i want
every single person
subscribing to the shot a lot of
pressure but once we start doing
cutaways at the dartboard in the shell
for goodness will probably get it i
think i agree with you hey a quick game
of league of legends i had this morning
without you sans billy boyd and guess
who i was playing against in mid lane
let me hold on
you know i can never remember any of the
names but you'll remember this game
oh well there's a click oh it's a guy so
straight away fifty percent are gone
mid laner
[Music]
midlaner guy
hey madanga correct answer how did it go
i beat him up in mid lane but
unfortunately our team surrendered i
didn't surrender because you know me i'm
not a surrenderer
no retreat no surrender
so we got two dragons they got two
dragons very quickly after that and then
we were going for the third dragon
someone put a surrender vote in and i
said no no we'll get this dragon and
we'll be we'll be all right four out of
the five surrendered and we were done
you know what that was you just did
there a legal legends update
so there's your league of legends update
i played the game yesterday
[Music]
we were doing quite well
yeah in the middle
and uh well we're doing quite good with
a good set
uh with a good who's the guy it takes
you in his world mordecai mordekaiser a
good mordekaiser and then the other two
one of them quit
and then the other one quit are you in a
three-man team three against five and we
were almost doing it we were in the base
and i was like if we win this three
against five epic with a great murder
guys but you didn't no we didn't win oh
that's a [ __ ] well
we have been traveling the length and
breadth of the country haven't we we've
been in this very short period here um
over the last few months we've been to
dallas texas we've been to orlando
florida we've been to calgary in canada
denver colorado we're also doing a live
podcast in boston that's in august yeah
but but you know it's coming okay it may
say hello and then they won't get to see
it and toronto which will be our last
one and also
um
the lone rangers mate that's true
toronto toronto yeah yeah so you can
find all that information at fan expo
get your tickets we uh tend to try and
eat food or drink drinks from the local
area
which is exciting and maybe we can share
out with people but hey should we do a
little bit of housekeeping
[Music]
true
yeah i went renegade i went jazz because
of our recent guests the potash twins
lovely jazz fantastic musicians and uh
they made me a little bit more inspired
to go jazz and i couldn't believe as
soon as it finished i thought i never
told my favorite gag
oh the trumpet tree when i was younger i
had a trumpet tree in my garden but a
man from the council came and rooted
scottish joke there well it only works
in scotland that's true hey so i'm going
to read this one because this one got a
subject very close to my heart here from
hannah hobner
in tyler texas who said my question for
you has to do with chinese food lovely
she lives in warrington very close to
manchester united england for a year and
when i was there i was pretty surprised
by how different uk chinese food is from
the u.s i like both but i miss the duck
pancakes and prawn crackers
prefer one on the other uk chinese or
u.s giant chinese and which food item is
your favorite well
you know this
apart from an all-you-can-eat buffet
which would be
my last meal because then i would just
gently eat a tiny little wafer thin
piece of cucumber forever and when the
wardens came in i'd say i'm not i'm not
finished
you know yeah old kitty buffet
apart from that
my last meal would be
crispy duck and pancakes sorry all the
ducks out there that are listening and i
don't eat that and pancakes but it's a
very thin pancake a little bit of hoisin
sauce
lovely duck
some
scallions or spring onions spring onions
kind of like strips of them and then
stripped strips of cucumber right it's
fantastic isn't it
what about you what would your last meal
be what's your favorite meal ever
um
that's a good question
maybe it may be a maybe a thai curry i
think
a green green curry or some with
potatoes
weirdly they soak up all that curry
but chinese
us or uk
is what a hannah is asking
i mean both both places do it
well i mean they don't do the crispy
duck and pancakes thing here in the u.s
as well as in the uk
but then i think maybe their noodles are
a little better over here
and i have a veg i told you the other
week i have a veggie fried rice from my
local place chi dynasty which i crave
when i'm away from him
well for me and it's you know it's been
a big couple of weeks for united states
of america because you get the 4th of
july you see that's a big that's a big
holiday
but
and i i love lots and lots of things
about america i think it's a great
country but when it comes to chinese
food whether if it was in uk or u.s i'm
100 uk i love the curries yeah they do a
curry sauce
i love it and chips oh that i mean prawn
crackers this is
lovely i'll tell you what happened tom i
was about eight years old no maybe a bit
older ten maybe i'd never had chinese
food
i'm i'm living in glasgow i'm one of my
friends i'm up his house and they got
chinese takeaway
and one of his uncles said to me
have you have you had chinese i said no
i haven't i've never tried that and he
gave me
a prawn cracker
with a
piece of chicken out he's chicken curry
and an onion on it
tom
it's the greatest thing i ever put in my
mouth sounds fantastic and you've been
chasing that dragon ever since i've been
chasing that perfect mouthful
the whole rest of my life i have a vague
remem remember i have a vague
recollection that didn't you and your
wife get really into a chinese place
near your place in glasgow and it was
your friday night feast type thing
that's my wife that's harley
the the the china house
on shelton road hello china house
glasgow and they're a chicken satay well
of course
with the prawn crackers
is my wife's
favorite food in the world and she just
went back to scotland there she have ten
of them she only went for seven days and
i think she had it four nights good girl
i mean well done good for you alison one
day she she she was speaking to me and
she says i don't know what to do today
i'm not doing anything i said get
yourself to the china
house
she says i had it last night i said
darma yeah yeah go and have it for lunch
would be a long time dad hey that's what
they tell you well thank you hannah
hobner that was a wonderful question
wasn't that nice now what about you i'll
read this next right wait you hear this
this is michael guernsey location
unknown well from location knows a lot
of people from there i've got a question
for you guys
have either of you played the halo games
if you haven't
i highly recommend them i believe their
story music and world building of both
the games and books are equal to lauder
rings
in quality in size lofty
okay the first five halo games
at the bunji
that's the company that makes some
bungie bungie error
are some of the greatest stories ever
told next to tolkien's works what do you
think of that john
well
i have played the halo games
the first halo game is has one of the
greatest multiplayer modes of all time
i'm surprised you and i have not played
that together tell me it's called hello
halo it's not it should have been well
one of the first jokes that i ever wrote
yeah
was um
i've fallen in love with a girl who
plays video games she had me at halo
hey
i quite like that that's very good that
the original done show it there um
so the original halo yeah
fantastic multiplayer relatively simple
the single player mode i genuinely think
that you would love right you play a guy
called master chief who for a while
there viggo mortensen was tipped to play
but it didn't happen right roundabout
the lord the rings kind of huge
notoriety master chief master chief and
master chief
is
on his own usually on a planet fighting
aliens but there's a lot of kind of
empty space so for maybe a couple of
minutes in the level
excuse me all the best yeah you might be
just searching around a ship that seems
to be in disarray and there's a couple
of sparks and it's dark and maybe
something's leaking and you think what's
going on there's a bit of a ghost ship
what's leaking here and then you turn
the corner there's a bunch of aliens
brilliant world
i mean equal to the lord of the rings in
quality and size that's that's a lofty
claim i mean you're throwing that out
there though
but i've had some of my favorite
multiplayer experiences playing halo i
don't think i've played five of them i
think i might have played three great
game you'd love it
i'll i'll try it is it still going is it
is it yeah you can play it on pc but
it's kind of it's a classic microsoft
xbox game but i think you can play it on
pc are you going to join me in the elder
scrolls online world i mean skyrim is my
all-time favorite game but the elder
scrolls online gets doesn't get a lot of
love hey the online community hey i'm
part of that community no sorry they
don't mean to upset your bills i'm going
on there and i want you to come with me
i'll come with you there's no i mean i'd
love to play so we have to
take our time
he'd take our time we've got a guest
coming up shortly and we can see him
over there and i think he's an elder
scrolls guy yeah it looks like
we'll talk elder scrolls when we go in
there but you gotta take your time and i
think what we'll do dom is we'll have a
day down my house
and we'll set up our
accounts and then we'll just take an
evening with a nice bottle of wine and
we'll just pick our character he said
pick your characters
as one of the best moments spend a long
time making sure it looks exactly how
you want it so let's do that the origins
of that is great well your computer is
if you don't mind me saying knackered
sorry billy sorry to bring up that
hornet's nest but it is knackered we
could do it on playstation we could do
it and then it may be
how can both the two of us play
we'll have two two playstations two
televisions oh to playstations i see
that yeah okay
also your song
yeah i'm totally up for it but your son
who doesn't seem to be that much of a
gamer anymore you said just as a gaming
computer just sat in his room but you
won't touch it no it did last week
unplugged at all
and now it's now sitting in the corner
of his room it's not even on the desk
what's he put in that space
nothing it's just emptiness nobody's
going to put on it
a sofa
lovely just a lounge with his pals he's
decided i don't want to play games i
just want to sit down good for him
he's he's um he's the exact opposite of
most kids his age and that's one of my
favorite things about you i love it
here's a comment here on our youtube
good job paige the friendship
onionpodcast.com no it's not even dot
com it's just the frenchman in pogus
regarding top gun
oh
says i have a i have to call you out on
your exposition complaint from billy
i've been called out nothing
he said this oh this is from trap
johnson nice he sounds like he's a
fighter pilot straight away
says yes everyone in the room knew what
the x
expositor was saying however the
expositor also knew that he needs to
perpetually remind maverick to not push
the issue
at risk of stuff going impressively
sideways uh-huh it was not exposition
alone it was a character be of i know
you do reckless stuff please don't do
that now
okay okay well i'm gonna i'm gonna this
is your rebuttal i'm gonna
here is my rebuttal on that dom yes and
i'll need to watch the movie again and
i've been looking for an excuse to watch
it again
but i think
maverick wasn't even in the room when he
started that exposition
i think he was on his motorbike coming
in and arriving late i think the general
was in the room wasn't it the general
was in the room
and everybody involved in the top gun
you know whatever it is they're trying
to do get to mark 10. is it mark or mac
i think in the states they say mac but
surely it's math that's what i bet every
time i do i feel like like a german spy
or something
isn't uh when that speech is going on
isn't tom cruise kind of uh he's
he's having nothing i already it's
before he even arrives but surely the
general would say don't you get in that
plane
pete right right pete he'd call him pete
or would he but he's the boss maverick
wouldn't he demean him by calling him by
his first name boy peter maybe he'd say
don't get in that plane i think i think
mav has gone up already and he's like
there's nothing you can do so last
flight i think that's what happens he's
like let's just take it up
what's the general going to do we're
already up in the
anyway i need to watch it again watch it
again it definitely struck me as he
doesn't need to be making this speech
right now
hiring if that word doesn't get you
excited to find your next favorite team
member you need the hiring partner that
makes finding quality candidates easy
you need indeed indeed is the hiring
platform where you can attract interview
and hire all in one place instead of
spending hours on multiple job sites
searching for candidates with the right
skills indeed's a powerful hiring
partner that can help you do it all
find great talent faster through
time-saving tools like indeed instant
match assessments and virtual interviews
with instant match over 80 percent of
employers get quality candidates whose
resumes on indeed matches their job
description the moment they sponsor a
job according to indeed data us indeed
puts you in control of what you pay you
set your must-have job requirements and
only pay for the applications that meet
them there's a transparent flat fee per
application and you can pause your job
posting whenever you want when you
sponsor an indeed post you're 4.5 times
more likely to get a higher according to
indeed data worldwide the right
candidate is doing everything they can
to find you and if you use indeed you
can be sure you're doing everything you
can to find them too and indeed's doing
something no other job site has done now
with indeed business only pay for
quality applications matching the
sponsored job description visit
indeed.com onion to start hiring today
just go to indeed.com
terms and conditions apply need to hire
you need indeed
dom william do you know what i really
love
liquor diving oh i really really enjoy
drinking those things and it's good when
like you're working out are these hot
summer months
you know what i mean and you're feeling
like i've got really keep holding my
hydration here make sure i'm drinking
enough water you told me the other day
that you prefer drinking liquid iv than
water well i do i like it like see i'm
outside doing a quick workout doing some
squats lunges and then i get a nice
delicious lemon and lime or something or
strawberry they'll get passion fruit all
these different flavors and dom
apparently
a liquid iv
16 ounces of water that will hydrate you
faster two times faster than just water
alone that's not amazing that's crazy
exactly yeah it also contains five
essential vitamins b3 b5 b6 b12 and
vitamin c made with premium ingredients
it's non-gmo free from gluten free from
dairy and soy and for every purchase
they'll donate a serving to someone in
need and today liquid iv has donated
over 24 million servings globally
fantastic grab your liquid iv in bulk
nationwide at costco or you can get 25
off when you go to liquid iv.com
and use the code onion at checkout
that's 25
off anything you order when you shop
better hydration today using promo code
onion at liquidive.com
since the last time we uh podcasted
together i saw the baslerman
elvis operatic piece and i very much
enjoyed it no he's a king of rock and
roll isn't it fantastic performance by
yemen
i think he's called austin butler that
might not be right it might be aaron i
think it's austin butler amazing i
wouldn't say necessarily as the spitting
image of elvis but that's not doesn't
happen it doesn't have to be his swagger
and his poise and his
love of music and love of all different
types of music and his style brilliant i
love the film i was swept away with it
and the music as a musician the music in
it is incredible i'll check it out we
should go what was your favorite elvis
um time uh if ever it was time probably
kind of
mystery train
that's all right mama ready teddy kind
of 56
57 era pre-army right okay yeah but then
i also like when he immediately comes
back and throws off all of those very
quick songs post-war kind of
in the ghetto and there's a great
version of if i can dream in this thing
as well what about you what's your
favorite elvis wait what's your favorite
elvis era music and what's your favorite
elvis era looks
music comeback
the comeback special yeah i liked i i
liked that it was a good band and they
sounded great and he was amazing well in
that baz lumen film the way that they
put together the if i can dream moment
is incredible
i look forward to seeing it now we
should watch it together and uh looks
wise
i love it like i said i think last week
i love the movies so and i love this i
love the innocent movies strange you
know the blue hawaii yeah and etc
king creole
well that was more
i like even the more innocent ones than
that right
have you seen him when he comes onto the
frank sinatra show and he sings frank
sings love me tender right and elvis
sings witchcraft and they switch roles
no
elvis is like about as good looking as
i've ever seen him he's he's very thin
his little gone his hair's very buffal
very very good looking at that point
lovely my favorite looks hey we've got
some voicemails should we do a couple of
voicemails just before
our
illustrious guest comes on lifty
hi billy hi dom my name is aaron i'm
from malakoff texas first of all thank
you all so much for coming to the dallas
fan expo um it was a dream to meet y'all
y'all are so genuine and so sweet and
thank you for what you do for your fans
taking time out of your lives to to meet
us uh i wanted to know what your
favorite memory was from the fan expo
whether it was a panel or something that
happened backstage that nobody else saw
um
definitely my two favorite memories were
getting to hear billy impromptu sing the
last goodbye
i'm crying and then hysterically
laughing later that night watching the
four of you learn the continental the
how the how the four of you are your
lord of the rings characters still
boggles my mind to this day
thank you again for so much for taking
time out of your lives to come and meet
us and y'all stay blessed
oh that's very sweet yeah if you guys
want to see us uh
learn cotton ijo in real time you can
find it online and we do stick to our
lord of the rings characters don't we
because about halfway through it sean
astin falls flat on his uh ass i don't
know yeah
and i missed that happening i thought it
was a bit i thought he dived at you
as a fun thing
but i think he actually tripped yeah he
fell but uh if you watch it you and i
have it down cold cold my friend um
favorite part of these conventions um
there's quite a lot of stuff you know i
do
um
i do enjoy the q a's because it's nice
to hear the stories as people tell it
and and getting the chance to sing the
last goodbye was lovely
just meeting people just
people saying hello and telling you what
the the films mean to them and their
family are just i find it really fun
yeah that's definitely the best bit for
me too just just meeting people in her
hearing their anecdotes of how it's
moved through their social circles or
their friends and stuff but probably the
standout things for me
are the kids are the new generation of
kids yeah so you've obviously got baby
babies that probably have not seen the
film maybe sat on their mum and dad's
knee while the mum and dad are watching
the film but they're dressed up as
little hobbits or little gandalfs and
stuff and that's adorable but
the kids that have seen it now that
weren't alive when we were making the
film so you've got nine ten
eleven-year-old kids coming over and
saying their favorite character is so
and so that for me is my favorite time
of the weekend so yay thanks thanks for
getting in touch nice good accent i love
the accent y'all hey guys my name's paul
uh i'm reading the new star wars book
shadow of the sith by
adam christopher that has got to chapter
nine and found that the point of view
character
is none other than beaumont kin and i
got really excited about that
so i don't know if you guys knew about
that but
great book so far and now it's getting
even better with beaumont back in the
action
oh
i didn't know that
i didn't know i didn't even know there
was
there's a ton of scout star wars books
there's a ton yeah there's a great
series of starbucks star wars i don't
know why i can't say styles
starbucks yeah i'm thinking of starbucks
um
there's a trilogy of star wars books by
a guy called timothy zahn z-a-h-n
that picks up pretty soon after return
of the jedi
han and leia have kids
a boy and a girl twins
and they're both gifted with the force
yep
so
they're kind of training them to be
jedi's and luke goes into hiding to not
pull so much focus towards his sister
and
is now brother-in-law and unfortunately
a kind of enemy shows up and threatens
his family so then luke comes back out
of hiding but by that point luke is like
on a completely different level of
expertise he's incredible i highly
recommend those books by timothy zahn
but that's great to hear that the
character that i played in in star wars
beaumont kin
lifting right over there
continues to
has a life there's a star wars
encyclopedia that you can buy
which talks over a couple of pages about
the couch that played in star wars and
he was like a kind of straight a student
at a galactic university and uh like a
co had a code breaking
uh talents and then he wanted to go into
the resistance and his parents didn't
want him to and so he uh
what do you call that
disassociating himself from his parents
does not see them anymore and
but then became a kind of brilliant kind
of um code breaker in the resistance so
there's life in the old dog yet oh yeah
we'll see him again
but um is anyone allowed to write a star
wars
book i think you need to ask someone
yeah i think if it's an official star
wars book that has the little you know
disney lucasfilm stamp on it i see it
wasn't but fan fiction i mean we have
fan fiction written all the time about
lord of the rings characters yeah but
like if i if i wrote a star wars book
with your character in it and
and and leia or whatever how it was a
time travel thing
and then i've been thinking about this
yeah yeah and then i put it out there
and it becomes a huge hit
do i get to keep the money
well sure we should make a few phone
calls about that let's find out yeah i'm
going to do that before i put pen to
paper yeah yeah good
should we bring on our guest hey we've
got a fantastic guest and uh this guest
is basically is based around a sort of
food and drink thing
so uh we might actually move over to our
new
billions or meet the world i don't see
why we shouldn't use it you know why
when we use it looks fantastic it's
sitting right there
and uh when we get over there we'll
introduce you to travis
zigler i hope i pronounced that right
sounds brilliant it could be siegler no
ziggler travis
zigler
billy we're joined
in our new uh billion dollar meet the
world uh stage set arena by travis
zigler
do you want to know a little bit about
travis zigler before we ask him to speak
before we actually see him or maybe
we'll see him now yeah as we speak read
the wonderful blurb while i open
a lovely bottle of mead m-e-a-d-e
me although we'll get into that travis
zigler
taylor tall and travis zigler have been
friends for over a decade that's 10
years now
in november of 2017 the pair came up
with an idea for a small leather mead
business
travis had been doing leather work for a
few years at this point and the two of
them began with their first batch of
mead in taylor's closet the summer of
2017.
by 2018 weird leather and mead opened
its first location in milwaukee oregon
after many months of planning on how to
get launched the first year was a bit of
a struggle to get the meadery launched
but in march they got their first
commercial batch of semi-sweet
traditional meat
in the fall of 2019
taylor toll and travis zigler
brought on doug wingate wingate wingate
who was a co-founder of the mack head
the mac mead hall and long time follower
of weird to the team and and as a new
business partner together the three
continued to build their brand while
operating at their milwaukee location
but
that was wonderfully red wonderfully
rare not easy
and then
but it wasn't i i met travis yeah but
maybe it wasn't milwaukee but i always
think of them as portland but anyway
without further delay
let's welcome travis zigler
hello travis
hey how's it going guys man
we've been trying to do this for a while
haven't we travis and we finally got
there
it's been a minute yeah um i don't
remember when i sent the box to you guys
so it's all about all the bottles
you have to send two packages because
billy drank the first one yeah they're
absolutely delicious no it's not
actually true i have never as far as i
know in my life tasted mead i haven't
either and we're going to taste
the first one here so you do a
collection of different flavors of meat
travis and just before we started i'd
said to you which one
should we start with first out the ones
that we've got and you said start with
the honey pomegranate mine
yeah so what i was going to ask you guys
is like what do you know about mead
and i guess one of the questions was if
you've ever had mead but you just
answered that have you ever had it um
never had mead all i know is that it's
made of honey
from honey yeah
um so yeah meat is made with uh honey
water yeast
um and then from there like what you
guys are drinking you could
add fruits or teas or
really there's so many different flavors
that you'll probably never run out of
ideas for making mead
um
but yeah you guys are about to sip on
the forbidden desire pomegranate
forbidden desire dominic
um and the thing that defines mead if
you're comparing it to wine is is simply
that the the difference is that it's
made with honey it has a honey kind of
base that is correct yeah um so
basically
the sugars that get converted into
alcohol come from the honey
instead of
with wine it's usually grapes
so it kind of is very close to like a
honey wine if uh
like pop culture or
if you're starting to hear about it
popping up a little bit more but it is
the world's oldest alcoholic beverage
it dates back to
i mean egyptian pharaohs greek
philosophers irish kings the viking era
um i mean there's a ethiopian honey wine
called tej
um so there's just there's so many
different types
spread throughout history and culture
that uh
i mean you'll probably never
run out of different flavors you know
hey there did you ever read the fine
print that appears when you start
browsing using incognito mode on your
phone it says that your activity might
still be visible to your employer your
school or your internet provider not
very incognito huh that's why to really
stop people from seeing the sites you
visit you need to do what i do and use
expressvpn think about the amount of
times dom you're using wi-fi at cafes
hotels you know
other people's houses airports
as you know i've just been on location
for you know quite a while i was in
different hotels to bnbs and airports
and i always use express
vpn because if you do that you don't
need to worry when you're you're doing
banking or putting in passwords nobody
can steal that stuff because express vpn
keeps you safe what i love the most
about expressvpn is how easy it is to
use the app literally has one massive
big on button you tap it to turn it on
that's it it works on all your devices
phones computers even your router so
your whole family can stay private under
one subscription so stop letting people
invade your online privacy protect
yourself with the number one rated vpn
at
expressvpn.com
onion use our link expressvpn.com
onion to get three extra months free
that's e x p r e s s vpn dot com slash
onion to learn more
we deserve to know what we're putting in
our bodies and why especially when it
comes to supplements ritual is creating
a new standard with its first of a kind
visible supply chain you can literally
see where each labeled ingredient comes
from right down to the supplier whether
it's vitamin d from the uk or omega-3
dha from micro algae in canada
i really like ritual stuff i i i've been
taking the multivitamin it's really high
quality it's got these um
minty kind of capsules so they taste
good they also use a delayed release
capsule which is designed to dissolve
later in your small intestine oh lovely
which is an ideal place to absorb
nutrients so if you're one of those
people that maybe you take multivitamins
but it gives you an upset stomach you
won't get this with ritual these are
supplements you can trust taking ritual
is offering our listeners ten percent
off your first three months when you
visit ritual.com
to start your ritual today
how
how do you go about making a meat yeah
how's it going
first question in the wine fermentation
products yes it's a great question
so you've got you've got yourself a jar
of honey and you're thinking to yourself
i'd rather have a bottle of meat i'd
like to get drunk i'd rather get drunk
than have this on my yogurt so how do i
go about making this jar into a bottle
of wine
yeah so
basically there are
about three stages of meat making you
got your primary your secondary and then
usually like your aging or your bottling
process where you would age it there as
well
um the primary is where you take the
honey
you add yeast
and water
really that's about all you need um to
make a traditional mead
um
i'm not sure how sciencey you guys want
to go into this but
uh
um to give you guys like the
easy kind of quick breakdown of it um
you know you add your yeast in there the
yeast goes in there and it eats all the
sugars from the honey and converts that
into alcohol um
you know in your primary you got your
co2 kind of happening in there as
they're as the yeasts are all gobbling
down on all that honey
kind of comes out um
usually in like the primary fermenter
you have like an air lock so that way
some of the co2 gases can escape
um
yeah so that's kind of the the
primary stage
um then
you basically
oh man there's a lot of sciency stuff to
it
go to science yeah just a little science
yeah
it sounds like um
that bread that everybody was making
right carry on yeah yeah um
so basically once you mix your honey
water and yeast then you want to take
your gravity reading
um so you want you want that number
right at the start um there's a whole
bunch of different techniques that you
can do to calculate that
but basically you take your starting
gravity and then your final gravity
multiply that by 131
and then you get your abv
your alcohol by volume and basically the
whole process of the meat making journey
you
you want to constantly test it and see
what your current
gravity reading is so that way
you can kind of figure out hey i want a
13 meet or hey i want it to be 12 or 10
um
and
what
sorry and when does it get drinkable
when when can you drink it
um basically
at
i would get past the primary stage into
the secondary once you get your
need to the kind of desired percentage
level then you can throw some
uh some stuff called potassium sorbate
um
basically
uh this basically kills off the yeast or
kind of brings it to a halt so that way
nothing keeps fermenting cool then you
can move that which is called the
racking process over into another
fermenter
and then this is where you would add
your fruit or
your teas
then from there you pretty much let it
sit for a few months
all right
then
after that you just kind of taste it
along the way and if it's your kind of
desired sweetness level then you can or
dryness level or whatever your your
notes that you're trying to hit um
basically then you just bob you can
bottle it and then let that age even
longer
um
so it's a bit of a process
um mostly once it gets mixed into a
fermenter it just kind of sits there for
depending on how long you want to make
this mean for
some people have aged you know you can
age them for four months some people age
them for like two years
um does it get stronger the longer you
longer you age them the flavor notes
will change um
so i think you guys you put it in the
fermenter it's not like a whiskey that
you put in a barrel and let it age in a
barrel or can you you could
yeah
um so a lot of people what they'll do
and what we want to do too with our
company
is eventually we want to take some of
our meat flavors and age them in a like
a whiskey barrel
um to get some of those tannins
uh you know or like bourbon barrels or
anything like that get some of those
notes to come through that's a good idea
i think i think that because that's the
sort of difference isn't it when between
like scots whiskey and american whiskey
as we have those
barrels with um
you know
sometimes bourbon or sherry or whatever
and it takes a lot of those flavors and
and gives a lot of different notes
what's this one done what we're drinking
here billy is the blackberry it's the
berserker blackberry and i actually like
this just a little bit more than the
first one that we had it's my favorite
up to now now is berserker is that from
is that a loader rings reference or not
or
liking movement it's very mixed so our
whole vibe with our business right is
careful yeah
i have a drinking problem um
you know our whole vibe
it very kind of goes down to obviously
lord of the rings lord of the rings for
me
um
i grew up with tolkien
um middle earth so
and watching you guys on on on the
screen so it's just it's a huge honor to
be here with you guys oh that's fun um
and so to answer your question about the
berserker we kind of went with a like
kind of like a viking
you know kind of style on there yeah
that bottle though i think billy when
you messaged me earlier today you were
asking about milwaukee versus portland
locations yeah
so
it's a good indicator to see how old
that meat is because i can't remember
which ones i sent you um if the
blackberry says milwaukee on it no
that's what it means this one's bottled
in portland oregon portland okay so any
of the ones that might say um milwaukee
on there
those ones have been aging for at least
two years now
since our old location
and we moved from our tiny little shop
over to our new whole medieval hall um
here in portland and then that's kind of
a so when you were messaging about that
i was like oh man did i send him some
old some older bottles
but it's good you know it it ages pretty
well so i think it's i think it's all
from portland and we're i when i when i
first met you uh travis i think that's
what really kind of
i found really intriguing is you i saw
some pictures of your place which is
called weird right w-y-r-d
weird leatherworks and metery yeah and
you brought me a a leather bracelet
sort of the leaf of lori which is i got
it yeah i've still got it it's beautiful
i love it and i've got some coasters and
stuff and it's just beautiful work but
then when i saw the hall
that you guys have got which you have to
you have to tell people where it is i
know it's in portland whereabouts in
portland is it
we're off of 41st and holgate so if
you're ever in portland oregon
just hit up you know you can google it
honestly we're starting to get so
big and kind of travelly now yeah that
we're having people show up from new
york florida georgia and like they're
like weird is the place that we have to
go to like right when we get off the
plane yeah we want to calm down if we
get to portland we need to go i had what
i had one day i could have went and this
is this is always a thing with me i
didn't go because i was super tired and
then as soon as i got home i was like i
should have went it's always worth doing
that absolutely isn't it
because otherwise you've got a night in
a hotel room that you could have at any
time and i could have went to your place
and it's beautiful it's got big open
fires you're just expecting strider
he'll be sitting there with his pain
that all the soups and the stews that
you guys i mean i look at them and i'm
like oh wow that looks fantastic so the
next time in fact me and john will come
up next time yeah um and we'll
definitely drink some meat and eat some
uh that
soup how would you like that one i like
that one better actually travis i do too
blackberry yeah just a little bit more i
think that's beautiful because i still
got the honey but because of the
sweetness
of the the blueberries
i find it a more complicated area of the
blackberry no this is splattered billy's
drunk already i'm absolutely pissed
while you drink your meat let me i'll
read you a little blurb here because
this will make you feel great about what
you're getting
yeah enjoy yourself open another bottle
it says here the ancient greeks called
mead ambrosia yes they did yes or nectar
and it was believed to be the drink of
the gods
descended from the heavens as due before
being gathered in by the bees because of
this belief it is easy to see why the
ancients thought mead had magical and
sacred properties and would prolong life
bestow health strength virility
re-creative powers wit
and poetry well you should have summoned
that then you definitely need to be a
little bit more human um yeah it's it's
a it's an alcohol full of mythology
isn't it which makes me understand a
little bit more how maybe it weaves into
that tolkienesque world because that's
also one of our great modern mythologies
as well billy and it's just lovely
though that's what i mean when i saw
your place you're like
well i'd just like to go there for an
evening well go then well i would like
to do why didn't you that night well i
was tired well you're always tired but
just to kind of switch off from like
normal life and look there's a hobbit
map you know you just feel like you're
on an adventure
you guys want me to go into different
types of meat yes please
so what you're drinking right there is
technically called a methaglin
um
so
a methaglin is a mead made with like
teas or herbs and spices um what you
previously had a second ago is a mellow
mell
with fruits i could have told you that
billy what's wrong i'm going to start
again because i didn't want the
blackberry on it
well i'm going to start again as well
i've got blackberry on mine we'll use
that as a wash sorry sorry travis carry
on please continue travis yeah
with the tea or something
and then we can dance then we can dance
all right go on go on travis a method
search far and wide
um
so yeah so there's
all sorts of types of mead they're
some of the most common ones are mellow
mills made with fruit the methaglin like
you're drinking there
the other one on the end of the table
there that magic apple that's a sizer so
it's instead of water we used apple
cider from a local farm here um it's a
place i go i've been going since i was a
kid
during like the the pumpkin patch time
of the year
the apples are harvested and fresh
pressed and we immediately put it into a
fermenter from that local farm and we do
it once a year so that bottle we only do
that flavor once a year
um yeah the magic apple um and i figured
you know you guys would like apples
i do like apples i'm obsessed with
apples billy likes apples as well but i
am literally obsessed with apples yeah
billy paid me one of the greatest
compliments he's ever paid me a few
months ago on the show where he said
he's never met another
human that eats as many apples as me and
i was like well that's one of the nicest
things you've ever said it wasn't many i
know i just took it as a compliment it
was just a fact yeah it's true cheers
cheers i'll read you another amazing
thing here that i just read about mead
because this is fantastic
oh that's lovely oh that's a strange one
i like that one
that's got a lot going on here check
this out bills that's more like a a
spell
it is a little bit more of a kind of a
spirit stronger alcoholic taste yeah
carry on all right here you go the
mythology of mead exists in our culture
today unnoticed by most the very term
honeymoon comes from the ancient
tradition of giving bridal couples a
months worth or moonsworth of honey wine
or meat this was long ago thought to
ensure virility and fertility and a
fruitful union in fact the payment to
the meadmaker was often increased
dependent on the promptness and the male
gender of the firstborn child
so if the married couple had a son first
maybe they tipped the meadmaker a little
extra because he's the guy that made him
yeah this one like billy said this one
has more kind of stronger alcohol tones
than the fruity flavors but i like it i
like alcohol me yeah it's good it's good
that's a nice let me see if i can get
the jasmine out of that hold on
yes
as you said travis it's like a tea or
something i can really like like leafs
i can so
what we did with that flavor is um
we wanted to make a we make a few
different method wins
jasmine dragon if you guys are familiar
with avatar the last airbender level
on nickelodeon of course uh israel had a
sanders favorite uh animated tv show
yeah there's a one of my favorite
all-time characters uncle iro got his
tattoo here on my on my arm very cool um
he
opened a tea shop in that show called
the jasmine dragon
and he's just all about tea so you know
we're a bunch of nerds around here so we
we always incorporate all sorts of um
inspirations from things listen what we
did with that we're nerds too
oh bailey watch yourself we love we love
people uh expressing uh pride in being
nerds because
you know in my mind at least being a
nerd just means that you have a very
strong interest in something and you
know what those people make the world go
round they you know they really have the
passion to change the world so it does
seem that you guys are
completely lovely the sound of success
right
you guys are completely immersed in this
mead world and uh and leather and
leather and video games we can't wait to
come visit i'm gonna use this as a watch
i'm using that as a wash you know slush
that so tell us tell us um
a normal day for you travis yeah at
weird leather and mead
oh man that's
i'm all over the place really um so
as you guys know i do a bunch of leather
work um
i want to be sniffed up
often
kind of drawn inspiration in all my work
from
lord of the rings you know i've met
billy a few times at khan with our
cosplay family you know we are all
dressed up in our like rohirum kind of
cosplays i actually have my helmet right
here oh great great taste yeah no the
gundarians are not a classy race it's
the it's the rohan people
they just have a little bit more kind of
style in panache yeah but they smell a
horse taters
you know
go on
yeah so you know
growing up
before the start of weird i was you know
i i was an am a cosplayer so i started
making my own leather armor and cosplay
and stuff like that now i'm trying to
get more of my work kind of out there in
the film industry and trying to get
more
like just armor pieces and stuff like
that to try to you know up my artist's
uh creativity
for the leather working side
also the mead making side so i'm kind of
on like both
sides here yeah um
so some days i will go in and i will
just be hammering out belts and
you know medieval garby type items
bracers um and then some days it's like
i'm in the warehouse and we're filtering
you know 500 gallons of need
or bottling or whatever
um
and then some days like on the weekends
we do like our medieval hall nights
where
it's people can come in they can get the
charcuterie boards they can get the
soups and i'm hammering out food or i'm
in the back crushing dishes you know
it's just kind of i'm all over the place
really isn't that interesting this isn't
that brilliant like you get an interest
and then that is your business now right
you know what i just thought in real
time just then travis and look if if
this isn't if this doesn't work then it
doesn't work but billy and i have been
doing
live podcasts around the nation over the
past few months and i just thought
wouldn't that be a perfect place to set
up a live podcast
you guys are welcome any time you have
to wait you guys want to come up here
good but do you know what i mean
we could have it
we could have a slightly boozy uh live
podcast edition where we drink a little
bit of mead we could have some uh
sweet rolls from the gut from the game
skyrim
you get to have the whole fireplace
behind you and the fire and the
cobblestone and the medieval tables
let's do it let's do it
we'll head up there cool that sounds
fantastic and uh
and as i say i've seen pictures of your
place it looks incredible we have just
moved into a new studio
i love what what would you recommend
on on the walls and stuff could you
could you give us a piece of leather or
something or a little
something to help us out a little bit
you know i mean
maybe i'll uh tool up you know i made i
think i made billy a couple of coasters
before but it had an onion on there yeah
maybe i'll make a bigger one with a
bigger onion on there and do the
friendship onion would you hold into
this big piece of leather that you guys
could throw up there you get some swords
and some axes and stuff and i think you
guys are all set sounds great
if you did that for us travis we'd love
that and we'd love to come up to weird
leather and mead up there in portland
and do a live a friendship onion any
time
this last one this apple one that we're
drinking now this is the sweetest of the
four that we've had it's almost like a
dessert wine like a portion
it should be the sweetest um
let me just give a tiny little end cap
on that jasmine dragon really quickly oh
yeah the thought um
we used jasmine flowers and a green tea
and we steeped it we seeped the whole
mead in there and let it kind of age on
that um
just to kind of get those notes kind of
coming through on on that flavor um the
magic apple is a super
special
need to me
um because it's named after my grandpa's
woodworking shop when he was alive
so if you read the back of the bottle it
says in memory of richard worshey on
there and that's uh
that's my grandpa on my dad's side but
he had a woodworking shop called magic
apple
very cool and uh
so yeah it's just you know that one was
really really special to me um but it's
also one of my favorites because i love
sweet stuff so
um
almost there was no water really in that
one it's just all apple cider and then
we add the honey and then we add the
yeast
so
the yeast they had a lot of
sugars to feed off of on that one i
might be over reaching here travis but
bear with me and william you do the same
but this
with a little cheese plate oh crackers
oh yeah maybe a little some some fig
chutney maybe some blue cheese write all
this down because dom will want this
when he arrives you know a little a
little we have charcuterie
little rosemary some rock salt you'll
have it'll have your rohan helmet on by
the end of this ball oh yeah there you
go this just goes it goes so well with
cheese yeah i think it would i think
you're right
i mean that's why we do the charcuterie
boards at the hall because oh yeah
people come in they get a glass of meat
or they get a flight and then they can
um
they just
sip the meat and eat the cheese and the
meats and the breads and all that kind
of stuff so that's what i mean
the vibe that we're going for what could
be nice it also says here in this blurb
that bead is the fastest growing segment
of the american alcoholic beverage
industry wow so to all the budding
entrepreneurs and beekeepers it seems
that this fermented honey drink is
tiptoeing out from the shadows and has
the potential to amass a fortune so get
brewing that's a little bit again
i'll tell you what that's fantastic oh
should we give us some scores though oh
now are we scoring the whole experience
i think that's a good shout because it's
hard to separate
can you juggle
what's this i definitely can't juggle
mead corks good bad
so okay so taste slash flavor
i mean i'm gonna go off the best one
that i've had which for me was the apple
one i'm gonna give that a solid
9.4 out of 10. it's nice i generally
don't like sweet dessert whiny type
things but there's something to that i
hear what you're saying because
sometimes a dessert wine it's just it
feels a little simple in here
yeah but
this one the blackberry
yeah there's something very special
about this travis and i like it a lot
it's my first time on mead and i'm going
to give it a 9.6 a 9.6 awesome thanks
guys and then
aesthetics or look i mean obviously you
guys care quite a lot about the design
because the design of these bottles is
fantastic i love bees
but the whole design you were generous
enough to send us a couple of t-shirts
which are radical as well so
in terms of design i'm giving that a 10
out of 10. i think that's pretty perfect
yeah i think uh that the t-shirt that
you're wearing just now actually travis
is one of my favorite t-shirts i've got
one too really yeah yeah i love it i
love the fit of it
send us a photo where else you guys oh
i'd love to yeah when i was first
commissioning this art from a local
friend of mine and he has art in our
hall on consignment i used to work with
him at dark horse comics uh
we
you know i was like i want something
that kind of symbolizes the protection
of honeybees because
honeybees are you know
drastically
getting closer to the endangered species
list i know dom you're very
proactive about animals and bugs you
know what was it you said bugs and bugs
are animals yeah insects on one of those
podcast episodes a while back yes yes um
but
so we wanted to symbolize something that
kind of shows our efforts on protection
the protection of honeybees
and honey in general so that's kind of
why we have a shield with a honey bee on
there to kind of show them nice nice
um they
they fit very well you've obviously
spent money on your merchandise and you
know you care about how things look i
think
it's brilliant um i'm going to give it a
9.8 9.8 now this is where travis you
might need to help us because the final
category is usefulness now apart from
getting getting pissed
what what other ways can you usefully
use meat could you could you stir it
into a dessert a cake a pie
a soup what could what else could you do
with meat other than just stick it down
your throat you've got to burn off the
alcohol yeah so we have like a like a
community group on facebook and people
collect our bottles and
i see people posting stuff in there all
the time about
you know i just cooked candied bacon
with some of this mead um i put some of
this meat in my soup um
i've marinated these meats in meat i
just did um
we did a rainbow sherbet mead and i
marinated a rack of ribs in it that was
amazing okay um
so you can cook with it yeah you can
drink it you can take it as a great um
conversation starter party or something
yeah um like most people show up with a
bottle of wine you show up with a bottle
of meat and people are like what's that
yeah yeah
because i like to marinade yeah so i i
think i'm going to keep the scores high
and i'm going to give that
as i've not tried it yet
an 8.7 nice yeah i've revised my score
because i was going to give it a low
score in terms of usefulness until you
told us trevor so i'll give it i've not
done any of these things either i'll
give it a 7.5 well i think that's pretty
good
well that's high scores for weird
leather and mid yeah travis it's been
great having you on
we uh we say this all the time but we we
always have guests on that work from a
place of passion and clearly you're
super passionate about about what you do
and it shows in your product and we
absolutely love it and thanks for the
gifts and the mead and the t-shirts we
really love them and for people
listening out there whether you're in
portland or wherever you are if you're
going out for dinner
have a look in the neighborhood and see
what's locally owned see what people are
making i mean look at the passion of
these guys the time that they're taking
to make this from scratch to have their
own place to have that art up there to
be making food to make a place that's
beautiful that people want to go to
look in your neighborhood for those kind
of places absolutely and send us more
t-shirts travis yeah oh i will yeah
always small wait are you small i'm
smart i'm small i like to wear my
t-shirt it's kind of tight you know
tight like
we will definitely come up if you if you
don't have this let's figure it out of
course i think that would be a brilliant
one what a fantastic location to do a
podcast that very every so often talks
about lord of the rings fantastic
we're kind of the makers and the
starters of the business but the whole
place couldn't run without my entire
crew so i just wanted to give a shout
out to devon christian
lutheran jaden april anastasia doug and
taylor
um thank you guys for everything
along this whole entire journey of like
five years like without our weird crew
and everybody making things work it
would not run as smooth and like that's
kind of how we're held together as a
tight-knit family
and um
yeah and then also
barry taylon i know i wanted to mention
this to you guys
um
you guys play league of legends yeah
yeah we do yes we do yes we do um
so my buddy and i ian we have a twitch
channel called gondor bros gaming
little posters here
well we cosplay faramir and boromir so
we did gondor bros gaming um we've been
talking about league of legends we have
never played we were wondering if you
guys would show us how to play a couple
of rounds oh interesting
i've never played it before and i think
having experts like you guys might you
know might make it fun
oh yeah yeah well we're the best players
too you know so i mean we've never
played before so yeah i think we could
maybe make that if you if you invite us
up to weird leather and mead i think the
least we can do is give you a game of
league of legends that's true that's
true thank you i know you guys are super
passionate about it so i just yeah it's
fun it's just really great it's just
such a fun game well travis thanks again
thanks for all the gifts thanks for the
mead you guys go check them out you guys
weird
meadery and is it works oh weird
leatherworks and meadry check them out
online thanks travis thank you thank you
travis that was great thank you thank
you so much
fantastic i've ended up with all the
meat yeah good for you that was great
what a great thing now we only had a
couple of little sips of each one so
just enough to taste it not inebriated
but it was very tasty i'm so happy that
we finished with the final one the apple
one because that was my favorite yeah
it's very nice so if you get a chance uh
go online and see a weird w y r d
uh
leather leather
and if you're in portland definitely go
it looks fantastic i think we'll go
there and definitely do a live stream i
mean that just sounds like it's
perfect it's a kind of an old tavern a
little bit like out of lord the rings
where they drink mead play skyrim i know
and we could do our podcast from there
we've got to get that sorted out it's
amazing and then he's going to send some
stuff to put in the walls of the new
studio which i love yeah
the shelf of goodness we'll put some
more stuff if you've got anything you'd
like to see in billy and don't meet the
world exactly if you would like to
feature on the shelf of goodness uh send
it our way and of course if you'd like
to uh rate review and subscribe to the
podcast it always helps leave comments
on our youtube channel
uh
where the merchandise uh at the
monumentpodcast.com that's where you get
the t-shirts et cetera and you can leave
voice messages for us at speakpipe
forward slash the friendship onion
we'll see you next week on the
friendship onion turtles
[Music]
harmonize with me and hold me tight all
through the night you're shining bright
i'm your host the baby you're my pearl